[Musica]
psicologia e leadership dell'impatto
sociale ossia di cosa si tratta questo
paradigma della sostenibilità e che cosa
significa essere leader o agenti di
cambiamento in questo momento storico
quando ho ricevuto l'invito per per fare
questo talk ho capito che in qualche
modo volevo utilizzare questi quindici
minuti per mettere sul tavolo degli
strumenti e delle prospettive basati
sulla mia esperienza che in tutta onestà
non ha mai condiviso prima
infatti qualcuno potrebbe dire che
questo talk non è per tutti è pensato
per quelle persone che stanno sentendo
che c'è una specie di chiamata in questo
momento e che stanno cercando degli
strumenti o delle lenti diverse per
capire che cosa fare sicuramente però
non è per quelle persone che io chiamo
gli entusiasti della sostenibilità
tutte quelle persone che in qualche modo
stanno esultando perché non si parla
d'altro anzi credo che oggi mister
rivolgendo più a tutte quelle persone
che come me hanno paura di questa
dinamica perché temono di vedere anche
questa parola sostenibilità svuotata nel
suo significato o ancora una volta
utilizzata per quelli che io francamente
considero degli esercizi estetici
questo è anche un discorso che ho
pensato per quelle persone che magari
vogliono credere in questo paradigma
dell'impatto sociale della sostenuta ma
che non ci riescono o non fino in fondo
perché per intuito o come me per
esperienza sanno che per decenni abbiamo
chiamato progetti impact delle
iniziative che avevano tutt'altri
obiettivi è tutt'altro e priorità
perpetuavano una una dinamica da
salvatore salvatrice oppure con
dipendenze o addirittura abusi di
culture e risorse locali
ecco è con voi o con noi che vorrei
parlare oggi per avere una conversazione
diversa più onesta
su queste tematiche e per parlare
appunto di potere e di proposito
quindi come in tutte le conversazioni mi
presento prima di tutto sono mai pagani
ho dedicato agli ultimi nove anni della
mia vita a fare ricerca che a lavorare
sull'innovazione sociale tecnologia e
scalabilità ossia quando sappiamo che un
progetto e un programma funzionano come
facciamo a diffonderli replicarli ma
soprattutto adattare parli ai vari
contesti locali in giro per il mondo
e quindi una delle domande che
ovviamente mi ha animato in questi anni
è stato quali sono quegli aspetti o quei
parametri che dobbiamo andare ad
analizzare in questi progetti oltre
ovviamente a quelli della fattibilità
operativa o della sostituita economica
quali sono quei parametri che ci fanno
dire ok questo merita di arrivare in
tutto il mondo di essere accessibile a
tutti di replicarsi
potete immaginare che vorrei rispondere
queste domande ha fatto sì che sia io
che il mio team negli anni abbiamo
analizzato migliaia di progetti da tutto
il mondo europa nord america latino
america dove ho vissuto cinque anni
africa e via discorrendo
ed è stato in questo processo come è
iniziato a scattare qualcosa
perché se da una parte questo è un trend
anzi parliamo di accelerare questa
transizione dall'altra in realtà la
stragrande maggioranza di questi
progetti hanno ancora degli approcci che
sono per esempio lineari oppure quelli
che io chiamo progetti cerotto quelli
che mettono un cerotto sui sintomi senza
veramente andare a guardare alla base
alle radici della problematica
oppure i progetti co dipendenti o come
li chiamo io un po dare l'azione tossica
cioè ti permette di avere una soluzione
ma ti rendo anche assolutamente
dipendente da me è l'esempio di quei
progetti che per esempio danno accesso
all'acqua in qualche posto nel mondo con
questi bottiglie di plastica con dei
filtri chimici
ovviamente il villaggio hicks avrà
accesso all'acqua per un po ma cosa
succede quando poi bottiglione si rompe
i filtri finiscono il villaggio ritorno
al punto di partenza e questo secondo me
non è possibile chiamarlo sviluppo
sostenibile o ancora i progetti che
perpetuano delle dinamiche di conflitto
di antagonismo io li chiamo i progetti
da trono di spade quelli che dicono noi
siamo buoni voi siete cattivi e per
ristabilire l'ordine delle cose vediamo
noi prendo il vostro posto di fatto
perpetuando una violenza di linguaggio
di approcci che è la prima cosa che
stiamo cercando di sradicare su scala
globale
questo un problema
perché se stiamo parlando di accelerare
questa transizione
su quali basi
ci stiamo dicendo la verità
devo voglia mandare siamo sicuri che
abbiamo la destinazione chiara
e non fraintendetemi prima di essere un
imprenditrice sono un attivista ho ben
presente la necessità profonda di fare
qualcosa qualsiasi cosa quando vediamo
quando siamo di fronte non è giustizia
quando vediamo gli altri soffrire però
fortunatamente sono anche figlia di mio
padre che era un teologo uno psicologo e
di mia madre che è un educatrice
psicomotricista e questo significa che
sono nata in una famiglia in una casa
che non appartiene all 1 per cento
economico ma appartiene a quello che io
considero il 1 per cento intellettuale
perché mi sono stati dati degli
strumenti e delle prospettive per
leggere la realtà che sono diversi che
includono filosofia addirittura
spiritualità infatti una delle cose che
ho comprato quand ero piccolissima e che
una frase di tiziano terzani riassume in
modo esemplare è ciò che è dentro e
anche fuori ciò che non è fuori non è da
nessuna parte cosa significa significa
che i valori e le credenze che abbiamo
dentro verranno sempre riflessi dai
comportamenti dalle scelte quindi dei
sistemi che creeremo fuori chiamandolo
realtà ma perché a questo importante è
importante perché solo attraverso queste
lenti possiamo capire che in realtà
questo grande paradigma e questo è quasi
dalle conversazioni hanno tutta una
rigenerò stree sistemi di credenze in
queste storie è il modo in cui volevo
raccontarvi allora parlando invece di un
altro the top in cui il professor
calderini ricercatore e insegnante le
politecnico e appunto di riferimento
delle in parti d'italia
non molto tempo fa ha fatto appunto del
togo in cui parlava del fatto che è
molto importante
esultare in qualche modo per questa
conversazione sulla sostenuta che siamo
riusciti a stabilire ma non dobbiamo
dimenticarci che resto il primo tempo e
iniziare il secondo tempo in cui è
fondamentale chiederci che cosa vogliamo
mettere sotto il nome sostenibilità io
concordo al 100 per cento ma aggiungo
anche è fondamentale ricordarci che i
tipi di cambiamenti di cui stiamo
parlando in questo momento non sono
risolti o non possono essere i soldi con
l'ennesima invenzione o innovazione e
tecnologia che risolvere le cose stiamo
parlando di un tipo di cambiamento che
ha molto più a che vedere con
trasformazioni cambiamenti interni e
prima di alzare gli occhi al cielo e del
mio ok mag grazie per questa ennesima
frase new age da instagram in realtà
sono le scienze neurologiche le
neurosciences che ci spiegano questa
dinamica ci spiegano che dietro a tutto
ciò che facciamo o non facciamo c'è un
sistema di credenze ci sono delle storie
ed è solo attraverso queste lenti che
infatti possiamo capire perché la realtà
che abbiamo davanti funziona come
funziona perché se in un momento della
storia ci siamo convinti che siamo
separati nella natura che stiamo meglio
della natura
ovviamente la natura smette di essere un
essere vivente inizia a essere solo un
asset da sfruttare da monetizzare
o ancora se in qualche momento della
storia ci convinciamo che tutto ciò che
ci sembra sconosciuto e selvaggio deve
essere dominate ucciso prima che uccida
noi potete solo immaginare v che cosa
succede quando questo sistema di
credenze viene applicato quando ci
troviamo davanti a una cultura che noi
consideriamo sconosciuto a selvaggia o
un colore della pelle diverso dal nostro
è solo se sapremo guardare a queste
storie e come alcune antiche tradizioni
dicono sanare queste storie che potremo
veramente creare un cambiamento diverso
da dentro verso fuori passare quindi da
una serie di lenti che sono della logica
del controllo dell'utilizzo a quello che
alcune culture chiamano lo sguardo della
cura o della madre o della rigenerazione
quindi cercando di ricordarci con le
storie che in realtà conoscevamo se
abbiamo semplicemente lasciato per
strada
ecco questa conversazione sulla
psicologia dell'impatto sociale
credo che sia fondamentale perché se non
sapremo agire a quella livello ci
ritroveremo con la stessa storia di
prima sono leggermente più verde con più
germogli sui nostri fire ma
fondamentalmente incoerente e quindi
inefficace
e quindi come facciamo e passiamo dalla
psicologia alla leadership parliamo di
che cosa possiamo fare
non parlo però della leadership dei
pochi di coloro che sono in alto parla
della leadership di tutti perché
parliamo molto spesso di abuso di potere
giustamente perché effettivamente c'è in
questo evento storico da sempre un abuso
di potere ma non parliamo a sufficienza
della negazione di potere del nostro o
della proiezione del nostro potere sugli
altri e quindi se come avrete capito
credo spero che sono una nerd che mi
piace guardare e utilizzare le cose
guardando alle leggi di causa effetto
usare gli strumenti che sono pratici che
letteralmente potreste usare in questo
momento se aveste carta e penna vorrei
proporvi un gioco
iniziando a delimitare il campo di gioco
stiamo parlando nel fatto che ovviamente
quando parliamo di cambiamento che
stiamo parlando del fatto che nulla si
crea nulla si distrugge tutto si
trasforma quindi parliamo di
trasformazione o transizione ecco
immaginiamo per un momento che
effettivamente ci sia una formula che
possiamo utilizzare per decodificare o
decifrare quella traiettoria di
transizione e trasformazione da a a b
dove vogliamo andare quindi una formula
per decifrare la creazione di valore
positivo la creazione impatto è che
questa formula si è la moltiplicazione
di potere per proposito ma che cos'è il
potere
ciascuna di queste di questi elementi
può essere decodificato sia su scala
individuale che collettiva a livello di
gruppo a livello di organizzazione e
sottopotere troviamo ovviamente i soliti
noti potrei chiedere i quali sono i
vostri asset tangibili e intangibili
oppure le vostre capacità le vostre
abilità alle vostre skill oi vostri
talenti le cose che per voi è naturale
fare da sempre ma ci sono poteri meno
noti che sono molto importanti
uno di questi è il privilegio che oggi è
diventata una parolaccia per l'abuso dei
privilegi ma in realtà i privilegi
piccoli o grandi che abbiamo tutti sono
parte fondamentale perché sono la
materia prima se continuiamo a creare un
ambiente dove non si può parlare dei
nostri privilegi non possiamo guardare i
nostri privilegi
stiamo negando alcuni degli strumenti
più potenti che abbiamo
sotto potete troviamo anche un altro un
altro elemento poco conosciuto le nostre
ferite
quali sono le vostre ferite c'è una
frase chiamo molto di francis veber che
dice è meravigliosa che tu abbia un nome
è un lavoro ma ricordo di te anche della
medicina
che è il risultato delle battaglie che
hai saputo affrontare e superare e che
possono essere guida o aiuto per tutte
le altre persone che stanno cercando di
affrontare e superare le stesse cose e
non necessariamente perché questo deve
diventare il tuo lavoro ma questo
diventa un linguaggio fondamentale
perché in coppa incontra le persone a un
livello che uno tra i più universali in
tutto il mondo non importa la cultura
qui questi per esempio sono i poteri
dall'altra parte abbiamo moltiplicato
proposito un'altra parola
complicatissima perché crea un sacco di
pressioni non mi dilungherò tanto ci
sono tanti propositi secondo me però è
importante sapere che probabilmente
avrete notato che tutte le case le cause
l'impatto sociale ambientale sono
importante logicamente ci sembrano
importanti ma solo alcune toccano a
delle corde in noi molto profonde a
volte non sappiamo neanche spiegare
perché
però non possiamo negarlo ecco gli dico
sempre che il proposito o i propositi
non sono dei concetti è una sensazione
fisica che abbiamo solo quando parliamo
siamo esposti a quel qualcosa che ci
muove dentro che chiama un'azione noi e
che spero che sapremo rispondere ecco
ipotizziamo ora che questa formula possa
essere ulteriormente moltiplicata per
due elementi il primo è la sfera di
influenza con l'essere l'influenza che
cosa sono per spiegare questa cosa ho
pensato di utilizzare un esempio
parlando di una persona che ho
conosciuto ultimamente alessandro
lovisetto che ha fondato una startup
armi studio che ha scoperto che tra i
suoi poteri loro vendono prodotti sono
stati mita quindi tra i loro poteri c'è
un ecommerce oltre i loro prodotti dai
loro propositi c'è il fatto che vogliono
fare advocacy poi che non creare degli
esempi diversi in questo settore e nel
loro svegli influenze c'è il black
friday quindi quel giorno a quei giorni
all'anno in cui possiamo comprare le
cose a dei prezzi scontati ecco allora
hanno scelto invece di usare questa
string fluenza facendo sì che i nonni
black friday invece di abbassare i
propri prezzi
li alzano dell'undici per cento
spiegando sul loro sito che lo fanno
perché tutti quei soldi quell 11 per
cento verranno reinvestiti nei loro
artigiani nel draw provider capendo che
allineare i propri poteri e proprio
proposito le proprie stelle influenza
con un'azione che non ha a che fare con
loro core business può veramente andare
ad alimentare il paradigma ovviamente in
cui rosti rappresentano o si sentono
rappresentati e chi adora interessa far
crescere questo è un ottimo esempio di
strà influenza e poi possiamo
moltiplicare potere proposito per
un'altra cosa che è un grado perché ha
un grado perché il cambiamento di cui
stiamo parlando adesso questa
transizione non l'abbiamo iniziata noi
sono decenni che parliamo di empowerment
e il potere e il proposito ma in questo
momento abbiamo la possibilità di
scegliere di tracciare delle direzioni
delle traiettorie diverse
bilanciare con la crescita personale o
della propria organizzazione
con un contributo al collettivo ma
quindi perché è una per cento
mi scuseranno quelli tra di voi che sono
naviganti o piloti perché noi comuni
mortali non le sappiamo queste cose
tutti abbiamo sentito parlare del timone
ma pochissimi sanno che dietro al timone
alla fine c'è un pezzo piccolissimo in
inglese si chiama trim tab che
fondamentalmente quando si muove anche
di pochissimo
metaforicamente di un grado permette a
tutto il resto del timone del veicolo
quindi di muoversi o di virare in modo
molto più ampio
ecco tutto inizia con un grado di virata
quando ci troviamo di fronte a queste
sfide questi temi che sembrano
insormontabili ricordiamoci che possiamo
partire da un grado perché io credo
profondamente che in questo momento
storico ci sia una generazione sulla
terra che non è una generazione figlia
di padri di una certa età come tutte le
altre ma è una generazione è figlia
delle domande che stanno scuotendo i
nostri tempi e dalla generazione che io
chiamo generazione gandalf perché
generazione gandalf quelli come voi sono
nerd come best ricorderanno che nel
signore di anelli a un certo punto c'è
una scena dove la compagnia dell'anello
sta scappando da una specie di mostro di
fuoco gigantesco molto violento eccetera
eccetera e ganda sceglie di far passare
il resto della compagnia dell'anello di
fermarsi di fronte a questo mostro di
piantare il suo bastone la sua spada che
archetipicamente psicologicamente sono
dei simboli potentissimi su questo ponte
altro stimolo potente dire tu non puoi
passare
la tua violenza il tuo approccio non
risponderà nello stesso modo
e tu non puoi passare ecco credo che
questo simbolo e g esattamente questo
che quello che la nostra generazione
gandalf sta cercando di fare sta
cercando di ritrovare quel bastone in
quella spada i nostri poteri il nostro
proposito le nostre stelle influenza e
piantare nel terreno dire tu non puoi
passare tuo approccio che perpetua
violenza tuo approccio il perpetual il
fa cercato tuo approccio che perpetuare
il washington
dinamica che prevede tra il dare la
colpa l'additare ti capisco solo dove
vieni comunque non puoi passare questa
cosa finisce con me e anzi piantando mio
potermi a proposito il terreno diventa
un conterno capaci di virare del mio
grado verso traghettare migliori
quindi se abbiamo quel grado se abbiamo
la partita di decifrare questi nostri
poteri propositi come li volete usare in
che direzione e per chi per coloro che
vorranno continuare questa conversazione
sapete dove trovarmi e per tutti voi che
mi avete ascoltato veramente grazie
mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]